this is trudeau talking about the  country that he admires most there's a  level of of uh admiration i actually  have for china okay i need you to  explain that one  um  because their  basic dictatorship is allowing them uh  to actually turn their economy around on  a dime what about all the other stuff  looks pretty bad it's so beautiful when  they tell you exactly what they are and  that's exactly what he did there  i come in with rainbows and unicorns  intolerance and love  and  lgbtqi what are all the other letters  lgdp l gt  and why does he admire china because  china doesn't give a flying f about  their citizens individual rights i sound  like a nice guy but really what i am is  an awful authoritarian